who has tried to get answers about
solving the noise
neighbors are Furious over update to
flight paths from Harry Reid
International Airport sending some plane
right over their homes good evening
thanks for joining us at six I'm Denise
Valdez I'm Brian Loftis our eight news
now investigators showed you how these
neighbors believe small planes would be
part of an updated departure plan but in
reality large noisy jets are taking off
too eight news now investigator David
charns continuing to ask the FAA for
answers and David the federal government
sort of skirting around one specific
issue here right yeah Denise so we've
asked several times about this map that
was shown to neighbors who live
Southwest of the airport and you can see
that these lines here the blue ones show
planes that were taking off before this
new departure procedure went into effect
you see it goes like this and then you
see this big magenta shape there and
that's representing the new route and a
hard right turn out from the airport
well the neighbors say planes never flew
over their homes before the FAA
implemented that hard right turn they
were under the impression that they
would be small planes if any but
chartered larger Jets even commercial
air aircraft are allowed to take off on
that path we'll show you that slide
again and this is what was shown to
Neighbors at several meetings you see
those blue and pink lines where the
planes used to go according to the FAA
and if we zoom in here you see it does
not appear there are many prior flight
tracks if any at all over the Shaded
region that is the new one so I
repeatedly asked the FAA about this in
this specific image here I haven't
gotten the simple yes or no if this is
wrong here's what a neighbor told me
about buying a house miles away from the
airport
you knew you were moving near the
airport but you're not next to the
airport yeah we did choose to live near
the airport but the flight paths have
been established for I don't know how
long
but the flight pass or the flight pass
and that's what we bought the
understanding of this part of town
so we've sent the FAA several questions
about this and this is the response that
I got as we explained before the FAA was
completely transparent about the changes
we were proposing and ultimately
implemented we explained the proposed
changes to this Runway and the
departures on display boards that we
showed at our public workshops and
posted on our website in that picture is
what was shown the faa's own studies
found there would be no environmental or
any sound impact from that change but
that doesn't really make any sense if
the people you just saw all standing
there in that group who live below the
path these planes say this was never an
issue before we will keep asking I'm
David charns eight news now Brian David
thank you for that now you can watch
David's investigation and hear what an
aviation expert had to say about what
the FAA is doing at the airport versus
what neighbors say they were told right
now on our website and inside our 8 News
Now app